hi good afternoon I'm Kevin Noblet
managing editor for wealth management
little redundant sounding at Dow Jones
and welcome we've got a panel that I'm
honored to be moderating I'm gonna let
them do the talking we're going to keep
the format informal we'll have a
conversation for about a half an hour
and then we'll invite anyone who's
interested just by say brew tradition to
come up and speak as long as they're a
sable member as long as they identify
themselves when policemen go to parties
they get asked to fix tickets and when
journalists get invited to parties they
get asked to predict the stock market if
they're being honest both will tell you
they don't really know how to do it well
at least journalists don't know how to
predict the stock market these days
though at parties a lot of being told by
other people just how scary the markets
seemed to them how alienated they've
become with markets how the game seems
rigged how all kinds of complex
inexplicable things are happening and
anybody who just listen to the last
conference where you heard expressions
like prices aren't based on anything
real I think there's a general sense in
the population of just that kind of
problem we have a panel assembled here
that's really in a very good position to
discuss this it'll take a little bit of
a technology viewpoint but not entirely
we have an Cates
Smith well let me and Kate Smith maybe
just indicate who you are and she's the
senior editor at Kiplinger's Personal
Finance she also worked at the street US
News World and port and USA Today and I
won't go through a retired by
you've got those in your programs what I
asked each of the participants to do
instead was to give me a a good and bad
stock investment that they had made in
their in their lives
and an bought shares and a tech IPO in
1999 and it did I think it went up the
first day but then never hit the share
value again am i right yes all right
that was her worst purchase her best was
she bought into a a prepaid tuition plan
instead of into a five to nine so that
when 2008 happened she didn't lose 40%
of the value of it
David Lauer is also here sitting in the
middle he's a consultant on market
structure and designer of trading
technology he worked for Austin trading
and Citadel Investment Group he
testified to Congress about what he
described as a crisis in the markets and
the potential for new crashes that would
make the May 2010 flash crash look tame
by comparison
perhaps Dave's best investment was he
bought Bitcoin at 3 bucks I think he
lost 10 percent yesterday but but he's
still very much on the winning side of
that family we have an looks he's vice
president and head of US equity trading
at t rowe price mutual fund company he
also testified to Congress about
high-frequency trading which he
described as death by a thousand cuts to
market integrity
he buys t rowe price stock every couple
of weeks considers that a good move and
he bought old Maryland National Bank
preferred shares for his mom and she got
a new kitchen out of that
right Jerry Davis professor of
management and sociology at the
University of Michigan's Ross School of
Business he focuses on a lot of things
among them how corporate social
responsibility has evolved or devolved
depending on how you're looking at it
and on whether shareholder capitalism
really works his personal investment
history is pretty boring he tells me
just by an old guy who leans a little
towards socially responsible funds and
he only checks his portfolio four times
a year but as boring as he is about his
own investments he's pretty exciting
when he talks about the markets and the
financial catastrophe we can look
forward to the poem and Gail Marx Jarvis
syndicated personal finance writer
columnist at the Chicago Tribune
she bought ETFs and gold mining
companies not too long ago and she's
down about 25 percent on that investment
but she got out of tech and advised her
readers to get out of tech it's just a
few days before the crash in 2000 mark I
don't think her husband was out though
he was still in it no investment you
write a column you tell everyone to get
on a tack then you find out your husband
was buying bad you have to ask yourself
if the investment in that husband was
good
Gayle's also an author and her latest
book is called saving for retirement
without living like a pauper or winning
the lottery
um and that reference to gambling is a
nice place for us to start there's
nothing new about the idea of describing
they're thinking about the stock market
as a casino but never has the have so
many average citizens had a stake in
that game in that casino as they do now
and they we might even say we are
petrified by what we read in the news
about the markets hyper fast algorithmic
trading black boxes dark pools complex
derivatives insider deals rate
manipulation hedge fund shenanigans
widespread corporate greed and probably
a dozen other topics that I just haven't
listed there David maybe you can start
us out because you've actually looked
inside a black box or two how ugly is it
in there
well Goldman has the best quote on this
and when they were afraid that their
source code was stolen by a former
employee they said in the wrong hands
this could be used to manipulate markets
via copy of statement being Goldman as
the right hands and I would say that
many people working in the industry
don't believe there they're setting out
to manipulate markets they're looking at
they study the market and they look for
in efficiencies and that's been natural
over the course of the market for a very
long time what you see is when you have
structural inefficiencies in an
extremely complex system those
inefficiencies don't get armed away they
don't go away and that's I think one of
the main criticisms of high-frequency
trading and certainly the complex market
that we are confronted with today
created by regulatory regulations and
the fragmentation of the market into now
to I think 17 exchanges 50 dark pools
it's more than those of us who are
trading in it could really understand
it's certainly more than the average
person could understand and I think the
complexity and the difficulty in
understanding what's happening and the
relationship of prices to enterprise
value is that the previous speakers were
talking about is something that people
fear a lot and and they fear that the
market movements are somewhat divorced
from reality and inexplicable at this
point I remember we had a speaker at the
seibu conference in New York not too
long ago Larry Leibovitz
hi hi official at the New York Stock
Exchange and brother of John Stewart who
was trying you know in a somewhat
passionate way to make an argument that
the little guy is protected by the
system I see you smiling about that what
was remarkable to me is he had to use a
whole out of six syllable words to try
to explain this principle to people and
I'm thinking if you got to use six
syllable words to tell the little guy
that is interests or looked after then
you're just not going to succeed I'll
tell you from the perspective of a
high-frequency trader the little guy is
the juiciest of all you you do this
thing called order flow classification
it gets complicated but basically what
it means is if that retail order ever
makes it to market and it usually
doesn't because it's filled by
internalization systems at Citadel or at
night capital but if it ever makes it to
market that's the juicy flow that's what
you want because it's totally uninformed
and they'll pay the spread every time so
just a little inside tidbit David you
also testified I think the same day to
Congress as and and but I'm sorry Annie
you did but on but but on a slightly
different aspect of the markets maybe
you could talk just a little bit about
that yeah so I think you know everybody
likes to say and likes to frame their
conversation about the markets as if
they are particularly interested in the
little guy and the individual investor
and institutional investors like to a
price are an aggregation of millions of
little guys and gals so we represent
everybody and so David talked about the
the juicy order flow of the
retail investors but some respects
that's also us as we try and mimic and
and disguise our order flow often
looking like retail and and so we're
we're in the midst of this this big game
that's going on here and some of the
challenges to market structure and
frankly all of you all are represented
in this too because you have 401 k plans
or defined benefit plans 529 college
savings plans all kinds of things that
are all sort of commingled if you will
in the marketplace and our sense is that
we have become overly complicated and
we've lost sort of the the reason that
the markets were created to begin with
and who they were supposed to serve so I
think David said there's 17 exchanges I
thought we were at 13 but in any case
they're a few too many in the United
States and we have 40 plus or 50 plus
dark pools that really provide no
transparency to investors and really
very limited benefit to price discovery
and I do David and I probably agree on a
lot of things we might disagree on on
the creation of enterprise value I think
the market is efficient over time in the
pricing of securities and investors of
all classes should feel comfortable
about that but there is a game going on
here and a lot of people have been
incented through regulation and and
arbitrage opportunities that are not
self-correcting if you will have figured
out a way to interposition themselves in
between true investor interest and
market makers and other intermediaries
have been part of the marketplace
forever and and they're good for the
market when they operate appropriately
I think our sense is that there is today
there there are some advantages that
they are getting that are not fair and
we would love to see some experiments
some pilot programs the SEC and others
engage in some real really constructive
360 sort of self evaluation we haven't
done that
long time you know all these things
we've done how are they how are they
doing how they performing what was the
last time you all didn't get a review
from your boss I'm guessing it happens
every six months or once a year I hope
it does you should get that we need to
review the marketplace we need to
examine what we're doing and how we're
performing and we've been reluctant to
do that and we don't have the answers we
don't suggest we have the answers it's
highly complex but there's stuff going
on it's undermining investor confidence
and at the end of the day that's really
what we're self interested in because
our sole focus is to serve investors if
investors don't feel good that's bad for
our business and we'd like to correct
that the individuals don't feel good oh
and I heard you testify what's really
interesting is how this actually affects
individuals with mutual funds so you're
out there trying to decide if you should
buy a stock or sell a stock but what you
described is all these other characters
are purposefully sending signals
basically phony decisions to buy or sell
a stock so that when you buy my stock in
your mutual fund and then I'm counting
on to do well you may buy it at a higher
price than you need to or sell it and
then I the mutual fund investor is hurt
by that absolutely right so if I said do
you all that I don't know 94 95 96 97
times out of a hundred that I stated
publicly I wanted to buy a hundred
shares of General Electric I canceled
that order 95 percent of the time before
anybody could respond to it
would you think that that was
disingenuous would you think that that
there's something wrong with that would
you think that that I was playing a game
that that should be sort of exposed that
is a game but you don't have to play it
individual investors don't have to play
that game the best the the best
protection for the little guy is the
little guy or gal herself who starts out
not looking at
what the markets going to do today or if
I get GE a tiny bit better or worse in
an hour but if I own G for 5 10 20 years
I think checking your portfolio once
every quarter instead of once every hour
or even once every week is you know much
better I think
I think gaming the market is a huge
concern with investors I hear all the
time the people are losing confidence
they think the game is rigged they don't
think it's a place for them but they
don't have to play the game they start
out with an investment plan they think
like a business owner or even a good
shopper you you buy when stocks are
inexpensive you hold them as long as the
business model pans out and when they
get expensive when they get expensive
you lighten up
you do that by rebalancing your
portfolio which is you know tough to
discipline yourself to do but you know
the little guy can protect himself
I think Gail's point though and it's a
critical one and one that Andy I think
would agree with is that we are all
invested because we do generally all
owned shares and mutual funds and ETFs
and as they go to market with their
large institutional orders as they
rebalance or as they have to take in
your interest and establish new
positions they're getting nickeled and
dimed and so execution quality and
market quality is a roading long-term
returns right so the impact as the
institutional investors go to market is
felt in a much greater magnet by much
greater magnitude 10 or 20 years from
now because they've had these these that
miss erosion and this inferior execution
quality you know I think and what you're
saying is is is right really thoughtful
and successful investors take a
long-term view they make the right
decision about asset allocation they
figure out where they should be on the
risk curves they
older they rebalance as things get you
know great investors play excess when
things are really frothy mm tech stocks
are tripling you know I played golf one
day I'm a terrible golfer but I played
one day with a guy friend of mine he got
an allocation on an IPO in 1999 and he
was told he got a thousand shares at the
on the third hole by a guy going down
the other fairway who happened to know
his broker and when we finished the turn
at the ninth hole he was told it was up
300% and I looked at the guy said you
just made a lot of money you up sell it
right now and he said well if I sell it
right now I won't get the next
allocation I said oh so I I think he
ended up making a little bit of money
but not a lot but my point is that that
you know a lot of this is noise to a lot
of people and markets open on time they
close on time trades settle mostly
things work but in between 9:30 and 4:00
o'clock there's a lot of a lot of
gamesmanship and and things going on
that are not very or not things that are
that are being done well or that are
serving investors and overtime and that
does detract from the performance of
everybody because we represent all those
individual investors and what we're
saying is some of the activity of market
makers and intermediaries is okay but
some of it today is not good and there's
been this incredible aggressive push for
speed speed to the market speed the data
speed speed speed and speed kills speed
is reckless and we've got to slow down a
little bit and trying to understand
what's proper and legitimate market
information and market data and what is
what's noise that's causing you to be
distracted and to that misrepresents
true investing interest and and that's
the part that is unsettling I think and
it frankly has led to the flash crash
some of the stuff with a Facebook
opening some of the stuff at night
securities so many people feel that the
basic foundation and infrastructure
under the markets has been torn away and
really the markets are not as stable as
they need to be because
in this quest for speed we've removed a
lot of impediments that slow things down
and things like double-checking things
like being careful things like making
sure you can do things things like
redundancy which is incredibly important
in markets so Jerry Jerry I want to get
you in the conversation you say you're a
buy-and-hold guy so you but so you'd say
you believe in that investing philosophy
but don't you keep yourself up at night
sometimes when you do those studies that
that indicate corporate governance and
and is is seems to be on a irrevocably
irrevocable decline so I do have a bunch
of concerns when we talk about the
little guy and your friend on the golf
course that friend on the golf course is
not the little guy according to the feds
latest survey fifteen percent of
households own stock directly even one
share so if you see that commercial for
a trade with the baby on his Blackberry
I thought that was documentary footage
it turns out that is not actually what
happens almost nobody actually buys
shares directly they buy from tiró price
they buy exchange-traded funds or mutual
funds and that numbers also gone down a
bunch that had reached a high in 2007 at
about fifty three percent of households
it's now at less than 50% for the first
time in 15 years
so participation in the markets is sort
of broad but not very deep the median
portfolio is only $29,000 so people are
invested about one Torre's words in the
market on average if they're invested I
think is worth keeping that in mind on
the demand side the people that are
going to make reforms are going to be
Andy and Friends the people the
institutional investors the individuals
probably don't have a chance that what
dave says is correct we don't have a
chance don't even try and game the
system you're going to invest through
intermediaries and hope that you picked
the right one my concern is really on
the the the selling side rather than the
demand side which is that the number of
IPOs still hasn't turned around
I got half as many public corporations
today as we did 15 years ago and it
keeps going down as the Eastman Kodak
get delisted and then Zynga goes public
which I hope my pension is invested it
is not intended as investment advice by
the way and they thought they were gonna
fix it with the JOBS Act it was all
because of sarbanes-oxley but in the
years since the JOBS Act there been 20
percent fewer IPOs than in the year
before the JOBS Act so I don't think
that's the problem I think that there's
a there's a drought of public offerings
and that's probably my biggest concern
but I think a lot of that has to do with
confidence in the stock market and
understanding the stock market and an
exact chief executive doesn't want to go
public if they don't believe that their
stock price is going to reflect
enterprise value that it's going to
appreciate as they take actions to
improve the long-term prospects of that
company and so you have this drought
enlisting you have equity market
outflows from the retail side and a drop
in equity ownership during a historic
bull run that has never happened before
these things have always been tightly
correlated until now but yeah and if and
if CEOs with their supposedly
sophisticated understanding of markets
don't trust the pricing capabilities of
the stock market why should I
yeah I'm gonna take issue with what Dave
said there I don't think CEOs of small
emerging growth companies are not going
public or Delanco in public because
they're worried about the valuation at
least if the market's ability to value
their companies and their enterprise I
think they're delaying it and doing
different things because sometimes the
process of going public is incredibly
onerous and that's the part that the
JOBS Act was supposed to correct but
this takes a long time so you don't you
know you can't turn on a dime on some of
these things reporting requirements
you know disclosure you know scrutiny
there are a lot of things cost a listing
listing is expensive
accountancy and legal fees are expensive
there are a lot of impediments that that
suggests that maybe you know you want
weight and then you have you know
enormous amounts of money in private
equity and other entities that are
grabbing these companies before they go
public they're saying hey I you know
sell to me now and you'll do pretty well
and we can avoid all this other stuff
that happens when you go public
quarterly report
you know earnings pressures conference
calls a lot of stuff that it's it's hard
work but you know the market valuations
and and balance sheets today suggest a
lot of companies are buying their stock
back pretty aggressively which is
shrinking this flow out there and the
individual investors scratching your
head wondering what to do or whether
they should be in you know I kind of
remind them that last year the market
was up seventeen percent first quarter
we were up ten percent in the S&P and if
you learn money markets by the way you
learned zero zero okay and we do have
some inflation in this country and so I
don't know where else you go and the
great mistake I think that a lot of
people make is they try and be all in or
all out and that's really hard to be
right a hundred percent of the time like
that so good investors stay in they
figure out how to rebalance when they
think things are a little excessive they
pull back a little bit but you got to
stay in the game and I I worry that so
many that we're losing a generation
perhaps of people that that that that
benefit from the wonders of a solid
investment program that that's been
disciplined and things like that and I
hope we can avoid that for these people
oh I agree there are so many things that
need to be looked at and explored in the
market you may be regulated but in the
end it's the best game in town it stocks
over the long run will be an inflation
the bonds are more risky now than
they've been in three decades
yeah you have to be you have to do
something while you wait for people to
figure out what's going on with all of
these things you still have to put your
kids through school and save for
retirement and hopping in and out of the
market is absolutely the what the only
thing worse than getting slammed by a
57% bear market is not being in the
market when it turns around because I
gotta say though when you when you look
at the last 15 years and it's a critical
time here and I agree and you look at
the gyrations in the market it seems
reasonable to question our people being
compensated in terms of returns by the
amount of risk they're taking on and the
risk and the volatility is a an
unnerving thing when you see your
portfolio value change so dramatically
over five or ten years I can understand
why people are afraid you know we used
to have a wonderful fellow that was a
portfolio manager and analysts work for
us and he had a great sense of humor a
very clever guy great investor and he
used to say today is the hardest day to
invest today is the hardest day to
invest and I said what are you talking
about well you know there's always
things to worry about right so think
about that if you if you always got to
the door and didn't step through it
because you were worried about what's on
the other side you never go anymore so
you got to take a leap of faith you got
you got to stay with things this past
decade has been tough for investors but
boy if you had the stomach to step in
and oay toe nine you're looking pretty
good again forty percent yeah but yeah I
mean I I keep a file a female file that
I call anger and frustration and I had
to start a new one because I was ruining
my computer because I was getting so
stopped thousands of people have written
to me over the years
and they are the lack of trust is like
something I've never seen before in to
some degree it goes back to the last
panel so people realize that in 2007
Bernanke said the subprime situation was
under control it wasn't going to blow up
then we find out it does blow up then we
find out that Paulson and Bernanke have
to run to Congress and get eight hundred
billion dollars immediately or the world
as we know it is going to blow up then
we find out that they're printing money
like crazy and people say is a surreal
economy are the profits we're seeing
real are they jacked up on some kind of
steroids do I understand this then the
flash crash comes along overnight it
just skipped Bernie Madoff - yeah for
sure you know one of the biggest
questions I've had in the last few years
is can I trust my advisor and how do I
know and then you had Facebook and
Facebook was supposed to be the IPO that
was going to make people believe again
and instead it turned into a disaster it
told the little guy who loved Facebook
and said I'm gonna buy that stock it
told them that they could pay $42 for a
stock that probably should have come out
at 28 or lower and you take about one
more time first you take a bath on the
financial crisis you get scared by the
flash crash then you take a bath on
Facebook and the little guy says is this
really for me and your point is good the
little guy could be a buy-and-hold
person in mutual funds but they don't
feel safe there either and I'll tell you
one about the mutual funds the
industry's the answer to the little
person with a 401 K has been dump them
all in target-date funds babysit them
don't make them understand the stock
market tell them they'll be ok if they
just do that but that didn't work either
because in 2008
when the stock market was plunging my
phone rang incessantly from people and
target-date funds who were saying to me
my employers said this fund would get me
ready for retirement and I've lost
everything
well they didn't lose everything but
they felt like they had lost everything
and behavioral finance tells us that
when you face a loss it's the scariest
thing and you will give up on a chance
for a gain if you're too afraid that
you'll have a loss especially with young
people who have only heard of Bernie
Madoff or the flash crash or what have
you they're just not interested in
stocks and it's talking about being out
of the market at the wrong time if they
the the greatest contributor to asset
building is the miracle of compounding
and yeah and if these young people don't
get in the market while they're still
young they're gonna give that up by
becoming I have a colleague who's 40 and
he said I graduated I entered the
workforce in 1999 all the personal
finance columnist stoled me put all of
your money into a diversified mutual
fund buy and old so the S&P 500 was at
1469 on the first day of 2000 it's about
1500 now if you'd put that money into a
credit union you'd have much much less
sleepless nights and a lot more cash
again there's no there's no free return
right there's no risk lifts excess
return and that's something that you
learned in economics and in finance if
you're going to earn return above and
beyond the rate of interest rates or
inflation you're going to take on risk
so the idea that you can put all of your
money in the stock market and over the
long run you'll be better off there's
risk associated with that and that's
what we're seeing and we're seeing
volatility and risk and but that's what
I can
although two questions very quickly I
just I just want to make one point on
that though that I think part of what
we're talking about here is that
everybody's not facing the same risk
that a lot of people are alienated
because they have the sense that certain
players have reduced their risks by
passing that off to other players and
and from everything that I've read it's
not a totally inaccurate perception well
I think all of us need to know that that
the police are on the beat that the
regulators are looking at things and you
know that that people understand that
insider trading is illegal and people go
to jail and that you know when people do
things that they shouldn't do they get
caught and I think we can always
redouble efforts there but there have
always been people that are bad actors
in our industry in every industry but
the vast majority of people are trying
to do the right thing and I think you
got it you got to know that and you have
to know that when you read a budget item
that says they're gonna you know they're
gonna cut the SEC staff or something
like that you're saying why would you do
that you know we're all dependent on the
markets working well and there being
proper surveillance but I think you know
every it would be important for all of
us to know that the business is very
cyclical and we've gone through a decade
we've had two huge bear markets and
you've never really seen that before and
this is a very unusual 10-year period
pick any other ten-year period things
look a lot better start to your ten-year
period in 2008 going forward and the
numbers look pretty good we're not
through the ten years yet but keep in
mind sort of where where you are where
you entered and where you need to exit
that's the real challenge and you had to
exit in 2008 and sell everything you got
that what your timing was unfortunate
for sure but you shouldn't have been in
the stock market if you had to be
polluted the money in 2008 that's the
whole thing you have to start with your
plan it depends on your circumstances
depends on your risk tolerance
depends on your age depends on when you
need the money and stocks are definitely
a long-term investment three years are
probably longer you don't you don't have
money in the stock market for college if
your kids a high school junior that's
for sure
I think one of the things that Andy said
is critical and that is the regulation
side and the enforcement side and I I
think it's hard to pin the fear of the
market in the future of the market to
individual causes but one of the major
ones is the belief that the SEC is not
keeping up with technology with
high-frequency traders with market
manipulation as Annie said there have
always been bad actors but at this point
our regulators are increasingly unable
to find them because of technology
systems that are outdated or because
they don't have the tools and so as I
have spoken about on countless occasions
it from here to what's called the
consolidated audit trail we're still in
a complete blind spot and I think if the
regulator's took an intermediary step
and got on top of things with some
relatively simple technology you would
see it you would see at least some more
confidence returned knowing that the bad
actors are being found because if they
had just a little bit of insight from a
technological perspective the things
they would find would be egregious
obvious and easily punished under
existing laws any and when you testified
at that hearing in September I think
Senator Reid promised very quick action
because he said we just couldn't afford
to let this go
but I don't think anything's happened
since that it's it's the way the wheels
of Congress the wheels of progress move
very slowly and it's been frustrating
and I I guess you know what we're trying
to do is and the reason perhaps both day
all of us agreed to speak today is to
encourage you all as you can do so well
inform your readers to to ask questions
about some of these subjects and to
challenge assumptions and sort of the
status quo I you know I think the the
press did a pretty good job of
identifying the excessive expectations
that existed in the
stocks in the bubble of 2000-2001 I
think you all did a very good job of
telling all investors that the Facebook
IPO was pretty heated up and perhaps
unsustainable the enthusiasm and there
were a lot of columns written that said
why don't you look at it in two weeks
after it goes public don't play on day
one play on day 15 so we think it's a
good time for you all to be suggesting
to your readers to talk to their
congressmen and women and and and say
what's going on with this marketplace
how come there are these excessive
cancellation rates or all this stuff
going on it looks like it's gamesmanship
that's not productive and scares me and
the time to do that is now it's not in
response to the next crisis boy you bet
it seems like there's an irony here that
the problem the reason why we're not
getting more IPOs is too much regulation
and it's too costly and yet the fix for
getting more people into the markets is
more regulation well we do have a
regulation and we're talking about
regulation of behavior not not
regulation regarding you know a filings
and extents of the extent of about you
know reporting that needs to be done and
other things that are expensive for
small companies and the enforcement is
different from regulation its
enforcement that's needed and they
cannot enforce what they can't find and
they can't find these things right now
because the technology systems aren't
capable of it for the regulators I do
want to leave a little time for
questions if anyone has them step up to
the microphone we you know I don't make
it a little bit since they got to
confess their own worst investment but
it could be a little bit like an AAA
meeting if you want calm you can ask
your question and if you can very
concisely describe some blunder - I did
not buy facebook I'm a freelancer I
write for investor relations magazine
cover secretary magazine amongst other
publications I'd like to ask a question
about the technology and high-frequency
trading from the issuers standpoint when
I was in you know taking finance one on
one I learned that
of capital is impacted in part by
volatility and I got to believe the high
frequency trading lives off of
volatility yep I talk to high frequency
traders and they say oh no no we provide
liquidity have you seen any research
number one and number two would you
comment on whether or not you think high
frequency trading increases issuers cost
of capital what is the impact on cost of
capital high-frequency trading is a cost
in the market it's a friction in the
market so I would say yes it does
increase the cost of capital it's sort
of a straw man when you want to compare
it to a decade ago or the specialist
system I think that's a ridiculous
comparison I think you should compare it
to what it could be what an advanced
technological system that is powering
fluid markets could look like versus
what it does look like which is
extremely fragmented complex difficult
to navigate and high frequency trading
they thrive off of two things in fact
volatility and fragmentation and
complexity because it is their business
it was my business to study market
structure understand where the
inefficiencies are and to exploit those
there are studies all of them industry
funded that show volatility has dropped
and when you start to look at the
numbers they don't really add up they
don't really make sense or their
different ways of looking at volatility
it's an unfortunately nuanced argument
there are some more studies coming out
very soon by RBC that should demonstrate
that there are different ways of looking
at volatility perhaps more accurate ways
that show that volatility has increased
in certain places at certain times when
it really matters and that's when hft
sort of thrives it makes the most money
you know General Electric probably has
an average spread intraday between its
high and low of you know a percent and a
half thirty some sense I'm guessing and
their business doesn't change that much
every day I don't think their stock
price should either the other thing I
might suggested is we've been David all
we're talking about this the other day
but the the issuing side of the equation
and the conversation has been woefully
quiet if I were
or Proctor and Gamble or any of the
stocks that were hit during the flash
crash I'd like to know why someone kept
routing orders to markets that were less
and less liquid and that we're not
generally displayed and and and places
where there was no no sort of semblance
of best execution Accenture went from 42
dollars down to a penny who routed the
stock from $5 to 450 why did they do
that what marketplace was that what
what's that about how does that happen
and and and someone who took an order
from an investor or maybe it was a prop
trader whoever was it took an order when
the stock was it 39 to have routed it to
a market that was bidding 5 are you
kidding I mean you know go to jail right
now who who made that routing decision
so there's this whole there's this whole
subculture about where orders go and and
how they're prioritized in different
places that is really not generally in
the interest of an investing public and
that we need to talk about that we need
to ask ourselves are we doing the right
thing for investors for everybody by the
way only zero price but the individual
and you know that the issuer or the
sovereign wealth fund or whoever it is
everybody's sort of party to this
problem people need to go to jail well
it also with this argument that these
traders create liquidity you say that in
the in the flash precedent crashes and
you say there's many of them all the
time just littler ones that the traders
disappear they're not coming in and
providing liquidity yeah absolutely I
saw I can tell you you know one of the
the core beliefs officially for the
official account of the flash crashes
that it was not caused by hft and I was
on a trading floor in fact the largest
futures equity futures trading floor out
there on the day of the flash crash the
flash crash started on in the futures
market and we had the exact same
reaction as every hft shopped in or on
Wall Street and if you consider at that
point that hft was providing anywhere
between 60 and 70% of all market
liquidity and you watch the market drop
from down 3% to down 5
in a couple of minutes and you say what
just happened click it's that simple you
hit a button you're out of the market
all of your orders get taken out of the
market and this we took our words out of
the market so did every other liquidity
provider out there and the market when
you were watching it on the screen it
just it disappeared there was a moment
where there was no order interest in the
market and so to say that hft didn't
cause the flash crash is a very semantic
argument that is mostly made I think by
people who were not on the trading floor
that day let's go to the next question
the folks that get Co must love you for
hiding confessions I worked for
mcgraw-hill for about 22 years and I own
entirely too much of that stock okay how
long was S&P my question though is David
Stockman had a rather dire piece in the
New York Times recently in which he
warned about the disconnect between the
market and the economy and he suggested
that we're in for another big crash I
think is he right you know I I listened
to him a little bit in the back I didn't
hear the whole thing but at one point he
was telling people to get liquid and to
pay off debt and and be prepared and I
thought to myself wow my first mortgage
owner financed 14% the bank was at 18%
okay today we have people that are
working on my team buying houses and
paying three and a quarter two and three
quarters for a 30-year mortgage or 15 or
whatever it is and I thought to myself
this is a spectacular time borrow money
appropriately reasonably you know risk
adjusted
sort of carefully but to to spend to
invest to hire to grow so I you know I'm
a glass is half full guy this is a great
country you know we got a lot of
problems but we will solve them we might
not solve them quickly when you might
not solve them the way you want to solve
them you know we can differ on things
but we generally get there so I think
Stockman I'm out on that I'm not buying
his book
sounds a little alarmist yeah you know
me too when you look at the micro view
you know you know people get scared when
they look at the huge macro view but you
look at a company a company's earnings
the quality of earnings is very high
corporate profits are very strong
there's a lot of cash in those profits
it's it doesn't seem like a doomsday it
seems like we've gone pretty far pretty
fast maybe a little corruption but I
can't imagine her I don't see the
disconnect look I'm not a doomsday ER
but I will say that the majority of
trading these days this beta is these
days is based on correlations and so we
our mathematical models serve to
reinforce those correlations and to
increase them so the 2008 crisis we
would refer to as a correlation equal
one event everything was correlated so I
fear that we are heading in that same
direction I don't know that a crash is
imminent but I think that the idea that
a Black Swan could be around the corner
and it can be inexplicable can be not
tied to enterprise value or erosion and
earnings but it can be a glitch or a
reinforcing event of a positive feedback
loop like the flash crash was is this
certainly possible as very little has
changed since then and if the flash
crash would have happened let's say an
hour later in the day and the market
closed before it could have bounced back
that could have been a disaster that
that's why I'm I fear the next crisis
and I'd like to see action before the
next crisis but it wasn't a disaster if
you were a long term investor and if you
are out for the day you the flash crash
wasn't a non-event for you and luckily
because it was at 2:40 what not 340 what
people think was a disaster for them was
2008 and 2009 because we were a culture
the blue
you've done the stock market especially
the baby-boomers one-in-four had 90
percent of their 401k invested in stocks
most people got slaughtered and that was
people got out at the worst time did not
get it if you look at what's been
happening with clothes they pulled the
people have called about four hundred
million dollars out of the stock market
since 2008 they put just a trickle back
in and they put almost two trillion
dollars into bonds and my fear is they
could be set up now because they think
stocks are the bad guys they could be
set up for bonds and bonds can lose
money too with just a couple of the
interest a couple of percent changes you
could see big losses in bond funds
people have to know that they have to
know that there are risk there they also
need to know and I went back and tested
this after all the people called me and
said I lost everything
in 2008-2009 I went back and tested the
advice people are given to have
diversified portfolios so I created
really simple portfolio it's just like
half the S&P 500 half long-term bonds
and if you would have been in 2007 when
you thought everything was great you
would have just divided $10,000 that way
half and half you would have gone down
to about seven thousand one hundred and
that's when you would have been on the
phone to Gale Marx Jarvis say I've lost
everything what do I do but if you
stayed the course in less than two years
you had all your money back and in three
years you had about thirteen thousand
dollars I think people need to know that
because they still think they lost
everything and they need the
illustration which is why I I went back
and put it in my book had a first
edition come out in 2007 and so many
people were calling me and saying
you really believe it do you really
believe it do you really believe it that
I did test it and the new edition shows
people exactly what they would have lost
in each portfolio and how long it would
have taken to get back and for those of
you the right on personal finance I
think you need to tell people in dollars
and cents what really happened to build
up their confidence again we're gonna
have time for one more question and
it'll be from the incoming president to
save him I think Kevan Hall I have Kevin
Noblet manage all my money so there's a
good idea I like Gayle suggested I went
heavily and went all-in
in 2008 because it was pretty clear
regulators weren't going to let it crash
and it'll be coming back people cashed
out unfortunately Oh questions about
demography one of the premises is to the
baby boomers are seventy five million of
them exit into retirement and they
disproportionately hold 401k plans and
hold a bigger share of that wealth the
assumption has been they'll they'll sell
it off to someone else and at least
under the Bush administration the
assumption was that the Chinese the
Brazilians we're gonna have a much more
global securities market and I'm
wondering if that assumption has changed
and whether you guys think demographics
change the equation of the law the
long-term outlook on stocks and then if
anybody wants to comment also about the
Cheetahs which are high-frequency
trading in commodities I know that's a
got less attention than stocks but the
cheetahs are I think you might view it
answer that one
and so that concerns I think the 401k
has been a disaster for everyone
involved if you look at what people's
typical portfolios are they're pretty
tiny if there's a handful of people who
actually have enough saved for
retirement but the median portfolio in
the u.s. is $29,000 of the half the
population that has stock you can't
retire for six months on that at least
if you're living in a major city so I'm
not worried that the liquidation of
401ks is going to lead to a market crash
where we need to be finding other buyers
for that
I think the retirement system is just
broke the way that it is now we have to
declare the 401k a failure and find an
alternative I think that's the next
crisis for the country a retirement
crisis of grand proportion because half
a people half of people where within ten
years of retiring have $100,000 or less
part of that that they haven't saved
enough but part of that is that they
have invested so poorly financial
engines did some research that showed
that only a third of people with 401ks
are investing fairly close to where they
should be in diversified portfolios
that's a disaster and as we deal with
Social Security and Medicare that's a
disaster for the country no I I think
the industry has tried and obviously we
have a lot more work to do to really
push education of to investors about how
to invest successfully and it is a tough
job and it's hard and you know it from
your own personal stuff it's hard to be
a buyer sometimes it's hard to sell and
think and and we got a lot of work to do
there but you know the importance of
savings and starting early and staying
with it and all that kind of stuff if
you don't know that I don't know where
you've been and and you know every
everything everywhere I turn I see that
and so I you know I I guess maybe the
the target date funds are a good
alternative for a lot of people because
they're not going to be able to make a
good asset
and I'm sorry that that the average
account balance is 29,000 it better be a
hell of a lot higher for people that are
65 by the way Social Security was never
intended for any of us and we all did
decline it okay it's not for us it
wasn't intended for us you know your
your corporate plan was supposed to take
care of you and as we've migrated in
this country from defined benefit to
defined contribution we better we better
figure out how to do it well or get
better this next cycle because it's
that's key right and that is a crisis
waiting to happen because who's gonna
help all those people that don't have
enough for retirement well on that
bright note we'll see if this conference
moves from the doom and gloom that we've
it seems that prevailed so far to maybe
a maybe a brighter picture to later in
the day or tomorrow or something like
that I did want to have us thank the
panelists for for being here and sharing
we are bringing you live coverage of the
Society of American business editors and
writers conference when they continue in
about two minutes this is what we heard
AOL CEO Tim Armstrong he is one of
today's keynote speakers coming up at
around 4 o'clock there'll be a panel
discussion on the impact of social media
on media coverage and then at 5:00 p.m.
Eastern Federal Reserve chair vice chair
excuse me Janet Yellen she is the
featured speaker of the conference again
they are expected to resume in just a
couple of minutes and we'll have live
coverage here on c-span
we've been trying to break into this
room a little things a little better now
is some because of the lights that's
waiting it's so hot in here so before on
again the next panel in the Society of
American business editors and writers
conference will happen in just a couple
of minutes and get you caught up on some
of our